catholic charities hosted an early  christmas meal distribution event today  for hundreds of people in need all  across the valley  meals were served in a to-go style and  prepared by the catholic charity chef  the meal was sponsored by the franken  victoria fertitta foundation  which is headed by the fertitta family  who owns station casinos  in times especially at times like these  we want to make sure that people that we  serve know that we care about them  and there are a lot of people out there  that do care and they want to  give them something special today's meal  included rigatoni with red sauce green  beans and dessert sounds delicious  roughly one thousand people were served